Vladimir Putin has set Russia on a
collision course with America and the
West. Putin sees Russians as heirs to a
vast empire; an empire they lost with the
fall of the Soviet Union. And the biggest
obstacle to their restored greatness? The
United States. So Putin seeks to regain
control of the former Soviet states. He
wants to create a world in which the
US is just another country, rather than
a global leader. To that end, he's driving
a narrative that says, "If the US was just
cut down to size, Russia could regain its
empire and once again be the defender of
Europe and Christianity." In pursuit of
his vision, Putin is creating a Hobbesian
world of violence and lawlessness. His
seizure of Crimea was illegal. His
occupation of eastern Ukraine – again
illegal. Interference in US elections –
illegal. Cyber attacks on Baltic
countries – aggression. Deliberately
bombing hospitals in Syria – that's a war
crime. But Putin's Russia isn't the
Soviet Union. It's economy is the size of
Australia's. It's population is shrinking.
We can resist Putin's aggression... and we
must.
To learn more about my take on Russia, check the link to the book, "Rise of the Revisionists" in the
description below. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.